good morning everybody seven o'clock
here in the uk nearly five weeks into
the war in ukraine and russian forces
say they are scaling back their
offensive around the capital kiev but a
warning from the u.s and uk not to take
that promise at face value we'll be
speaking to the deputy prime minister
dominic ramp to get his take very
shortly and an extraordinary interview
to bring you with our chief
correspondent stuart ramsey he'll be
speaking to us for the first time about
that moment he and his team came under
fire reporting the war in ukraine
plus a maternity scandal that left
hundreds of babies dead or brain damaged
the findings of a report are due this
morning we'll talk to labour's shadow
health secretary west streeting and the
former health secretary jeremy hunt and
we'll discuss the former prime minister
gordon brown's idea to fix the cost of
living crisis it is wednesday the 30th
of march
repositioning not withdraw as new
pictures emerge of the besieged city of
mario paul the us reacts to russia's
latest troop movements
i'm live in istanbul the morning after
peace talks president zielenski has
described them as positive but said they
don't drown out the sound of russian
bombs
the worst maternity scandal in nhs
history a major report will reveal the
true scale of failings at a hospital
trust where hundreds of babies died or
were left brain damaged
nobody should have to leave the hospital
without their baby knowing it was
avoidable
it's
the pain is indescribable
remembering the spin king stars of sport
and showbiz will come together in
melbourne today to pay tribute to qriket
legend shane warren at his state
memorial
really pleased for all his fans
throughout the world
we're going to be able to join in giving
you a really good farewell
laser-focused fan trouble egypt says
that players face racial abuse as
mohamed salah's penalty miss sees them
miss out
on the world cup
what is it
tells me what
what's wrong with me
tv's biggest moments this year will
bring you the tv bafta nominations live
this
hour also coming up on the program for
you this morning wherever you're
watching us around the world we'll speak
to our chief correspondent stuart ramsey
to hear from him for the first time
since his team came under fire close to
kiev as well as ukraine's ambassador to
the uk
i have no authority here jackie weaver
no authority at all
she's just kicked him out
no it's just him don't don't she
and one of the viral moments of the
pandemic but an investigation finds
jackie weaver did not have the authority
to virtually eject councillors we'll
speak to the overnight internet
sensation a bit later in the programme
[Music]
good morning everybody nearly five weeks
into the russian invasion of ukraine and
vladimir putin's forces have promised to
significantly scale back military
activity around the capital kiev
following peace talks in turkey but the
ukrainian president says he's skeptical
and can't trust the latest promise from
russia let's have a look at the key
developments you're waking up to on the
programme this morning
uk and u.s intelligence say that moscow
has started scaling back troops from the
ukrainian capital but only so they can
intensify its offensive in other parts
of the country
excuse me goodness it comes after peace
talks between the two countries in
istanbul yesterday ukrainian president
president vladimir zelinsky called them
positive
the uk continues to sanction russian
oligarchs a super yacht worth 38 million
pounds owned by a russian businessman
has been held after it arrived in london
and docked at canary wharf
the latest satellite images of ukraine
show thousands of people queuing outside
a grocery store in the besieged city of
mariopol the port city in the southeast
of the country has become a focal point
for russian aggression which has left
its citizens sheltering without much
food or water due to the constant threat
of shelling
similarly thousands have also been
fleeing the northern city of churnyev
that's been devastated by russian forces
despite moscow's promise to scale back
military operations in the country the
president president zielenski has
urged his citizens to exercise caution
amid the still existing existing threat
of shelling
we can call the signals we hear from the
negotiating platform positive
but these signals do not drown out the
blows of russian shells
of course we see all the risks
of course we see no reason to trust the
words of certain representatives of a
state that continues to fight for our
destruction
ukrainians are not naive people
ukrainians have already learned both
during these 34 days of invasion and
over the past eight years of the war in
donbass that only a concrete result can
be trusted
has there been some movement
by some russian units away from kiev
in the last day or so
yeah we think so small numbers
but we believe that this is a
repositioning
not a real withdrawal
and that we all should be prepared to
watch for a major offensive against
other areas of ukraine
it does not mean that the threat to
keeve is over
i'm going to be talking to the ukrainian
ambassador later on in the programme as
well of course and don't forget stuart
ramsey will be joining us to tell us
what uh his experience was in uh kiev
apologist for my little coffee it's one
of those hangovers i'm sure lots of
you've had from kovid we'll get through
it together ali standing by for us in
istanbul this morning good morning to
you alistair so uh do we take at face
value the latest um from the russians on
peace talks
[Music]
uh no i think both ukrainians and the
world will want to actually see the
russians put into practice what they've
suggested they will do and that was an
announcement here yesterday a surprise
announcement has to be said from the
russian deputy defense minister saying
that they would would withdraw their
forces from around the capital kiev and
chernhiv in order uh to give um trust to
the ukrainians uh for further peace
talks now the question or not is whether
or not that is a genuine compromise by
moscow and where they follow through on
it or whether it is a strategic
necessity given that russian forces have
failed to
entirely encircle kiev and failed to
make any progress into the center of it
and so
i think what we could be faced with is
the russian reality that they do need to
withdraw in order to regroup if they
wanted to attack again
having said all that it sounds rather
pessimistic there was a genuine
feeling of optimism after the talks
ended around lunchtime yesterday that
both sides are starting to make some
concessions that are powerful to each
other and that we are moving towards a
point where
you know perhaps even zalenski and putin
can meet in person i still think we're
quite far away from that but i do think
that the gap is narrowing
thanks very much indeed
just to underline what we're telling you
about that super yacht seized yesterday
the transport secretary grant shaps
announcing that uh this 38 million pound
super yacht belonging to an unnamed
russian businessman had been detained in
london uk officials boarded the 58 and a
half million uh 15 58 and a half meter
long phi phi as it was moored in canary
pictures with the transport secretary uh
taking the opportunity to take some
selfies and some snaps
around half past nine we'll speak to our
chief correspondent as i said stuart
ramsey and his team for the first time
following the narrow escape from gunfire
near the ukrainian capital of kiev
i mean time still to come on the program
for you this morning in just a few
moments joined on the sofa by the deputy
prime minister dominic raab we'll be
talking about the shrewsbury scandal
party gate and of course the latest from
ukraine
shortly after the chair of the health
select committee and former health
secretary jeremy hunt will give me his
thoughts on what we can expect from that
maternity report we're expecting it
around about 10 o'clock this morning
and in the next hour the shadow health
secretary west streeting will give us
his take on the scandal we'll also be
asking what he makes of those
westminster coveted fines
but the true scale of findings at an nhs
hospital trust where hundreds of babies
died or were left brain damaged will be
revealed this morning a major review
into failings of maternity care at
shrewsbury and telford is expected to
blame a culture that favored natural
births and repeatedly failed to monitor
babies properly here's becky johnson
across shropshire there are children
missing
it's just sad you know we should be
enjoying the swings in the slide with
every other child
hayley's son jack would be seven by now
but he only lived for 11 hours
when he was in intensive care he's
always hold his hand
so
when i stroke his hand print i feel like
he's i'm still holding his hand
he died due to fatal errors
angry
more than anything because i know that
if i'd have had a cesarean he would be
here playing on this part today
and that's what gets you so angry and
upset
jack is one of hundreds of babies who
died or were left brain damaged an
independent report will reveal the full
scale of the scandal after parents
fought for the truth
for many years they've been demanding to
know why so many babies died what was
going on inside these hospitals
how was it allowed to happen
the report has examined serious failings
over two decades at this nhs trust
there's always going to be
a sofia shaped hole in my heart in our
lives um
[Music]
and and i can't change that
it's painful
midwives didn't listen to steph until it
was too late the cause of her death was
the lack of oxygen that wouldn't have
happened if they'd
come to me as soon as i arrived
she's determined it must never happen
again
nobody should have to leave the hospital
without their baby knowing it was
avoidable
it's
the pain is indescribable
the hospital trusts say they take full
responsibility but change will come too
late for so many families becky johnson
sky news telford
as i was saying that full report
we're expecting it to be published
around about 10 o'clock this morning we
do have reporters on the story for you
and as soon as we get more information
we'll bring it to you we're going to be
speaking to the former health secretary
about it we're going to be speaking to
the deputy prime minister about it i'm
also going to be speaking to the shadow
health secretary about it babies dying
needlessly how on earth could that
happen more on that to come
meantime the state memorial is due to
take place later this morning at
melbourne cricket ground for australian
cricketing legend shane warren who died
early this month at the age of 52.
[Music]
[Applause]
in cricket warren was best known for
that delivery against england better
mike gatting in the first ashes test in
1993
now known as the ball of the century
didn't know it was coming did he
and here's uh
there you go shane one reflecting on his
retirement and his home ground in
melbourne where the memorial is to take
place we all decided to retire in the
same test match um which was a pretty
special and melbourne sydney couldn't
have gone any better for me
that melbourne day day one in melbourne
was probably as far as
test matches goes and days ago for me
that was
just about as good as it got you know
it's my backyard the mcg
i think for a lot of us especially our
family it's a great honor to have it at
the mcg
he's done a lot of great things here so
he got his 700th wicket he's made a lot
of victorians mel burnings and
australians proud here on the very
ground we're standing on
really pleased for all his fans
throughout the world
who are going to be able to join in
giving a really good farewell
nicole standing by for us in melbourne
this morning um hi nicole good morning
star-studded castle is wanting to pay
their respects
that's right some 50 000 people are
turning up for a celebration of shane
warns life and also as you said to see
many of the superstars in the world of
entertainment and sport and media who
will be here many of them appearing in
person others via video link a musical
uh tribute as well with elton john
said to be performing as well as ed
sheeran and chris martin from coldplay
so in terms of a state funeral no one
here has ever seen anything like it
being broadcast in australia on all
networks and around the world
i will also hear from his former fiancee
liz hurley the actress and model
family members of course and many people
will be remembering his legacy and his
contribution to the world of
international test cricket how he
elevated the role of the
spin bowler and leg spinning brought it
back from the dead so to speak not only
was he well known here in australia and
in the uk he also played in india for
the rajasthan royals played in the uk as
well in hampshire and transcended
borders he was known around the world he
had friends like mick jagger and
hugh jackman for example and he'll be
remembered and celebrated here in
melbourne tonight okay um thanks very
much indeed we're going to be dipping
into the memorial service we're
expecting elton john to play and we're
also expecting to hear from people like
i've said elton john i think ed sheeran
as well not sure we'll find out uh
robbie williams as well so lots of stars
wanting to pay their respects to shane
warren as i said dipping into that in
our nine o'clock hour of the breakfast
show here on sky news this morning
meantime let's take a look at some of
today's other headlines for you now
the gunman's killed at least five people
in the israeli city of tel aviv in the
third shooting in the country in just a
matter of days police said the attack
had the attacker rather had been on a
motorcycle and opened fire at two
locations before being shot dead
israel's prime minister said the country
is facing a new wave of terrorism
and an inquest has concluded that the
formula one boss
max mosley shot himself
got some pictures of that for you after
finding out his cancer was terminal mr
mosley died in may of 2021 in his home
in london the coroner's court heard he
enjoyed a final meal with his wife
before writing a suicide note he'd been
in debilitating pain
pm is with us now also justice secretary
dominic rob mr rob good morning to you
thank you very much indeed for joining
us can we start with ukraine if possible
please um russia is saying that they uh
don't want to put kiev at military risk
and so they're going to move their
troops away how much faith are we
putting in those words well i don't
think a lot um we judge
the russian military machine by its
actions not just its words there's
obviously some skepticism that it will
regroup to attack again
rather than seriously engage in
diplomacy or anything of that nature and
of course the the door to diplomacy will
always be left ajar but i don't think
you can trust what is coming out of the
mouth of putin's war machine
to that end talking about diplomacy what
do we make of suggestions that the
ukrainian peace mission were poisoned
well look we've seen those uh very
credible reports we don't know uh a huge
amount about the the contextual detail
to it but it's very worrying
and we're looking to clarify the
situation with our allies
talk to me about suggestions that
mercenaries from syria are being
recruited at seven thousand dollars each
to fight for the russians
well we've heard all sorts of um
reports of that we know
that the russians have a long history
and are very prevalent around the world
in deploying mercenaries uh they've done
it hired hands if you like as you've
suggested the the wagner group is very
well known uh libya in particular but
across africa
and of course in the context of ukraine
and it is a warring side but it also
probably
shows you how dependent they've become
on other fighters because of the
weakness and the fragility of the forces
the professional forces and their
reliance on conscripts which we're
starting to see play out a bit in
ukraine certainly the the russian war
machine which had a a pretty fierce and
reputation has been found to stutter and
stumble in at least the early stages of
this campaign so it is probably also a
sign of weakness or fragility okay is
there anything that the west can do
about it
look it's very difficult we'll have to
address that um we've known that there
are asymmetric forces so uh hired uh
mercenaries as well as conventional
forces in russia um they're a whole
range with russia you have to deal with
the whole range of of possibilities we
set that out in our integrated review
you've got the the the fact that they
hire mercenaries they've got the fact
that they engage in cyber uh the fact
that they engage in uh
poisoning uh we've seen that in the past
as well uh the whole gamut comes with
russia and that why it is such an
unconventional adversary
but actually why i think the uk with our
allies are well placed because we do
look at every aspect of the uh of the
battle and the struggle
you've been to the hague recently to try
to start to talk about war crimes that's
a long process it will be a long process
but we've tried to lead the way if you
look at the response to ukraine we've
got sanctions uh we've got the
humanitarian response and relief we've
got the visas position on top of that
the pm i was very keen with the foreign
secretary and myself that we support the
international criminal court which is
looking at the allegations and the
reports of war crimes in ukraine so the
uk and i went out to the hague and we
offered support we've offered uh
financial and technical support to the
icc prosecutor on top of that last
thursday i uh hosted a meeting in the
hague 38 countries joined and we said on
the base of our package what can we do
together to make sure that there is no
impunity for war crimes uh in ukraine
the icc prosecutor was there and i think
it's a good example of where again the
britain is leading the way and you're
right it will take some time yeah i mean
the will is there but it's very
difficult to prove a war crime it is so
things like satellite imagery not just
to prove the crime but who's responsible
for it preserving evidence in a in the
fluid situation of a war zone is very
difficult which is why that support is
important now it's about what we can do
now to preserve that evidence and that
also tells the commanders and putin
himself everyone in between that they're
at serious risk of ending up in the dock
of a court and behind bars if they
engage in further war crimes or indeed
for any other action that they've taken
are you confident that war crimes will
be proven at the end of this war in
ukraine
well this is for the icc to decide but
we've been here before in yugoslavia in
rwanda um in sierra leone and the uk has
got a long history dating back to
nuremberg of supporting war crimes
accountability and again the prime
minister has uh with me and with the
foreign secretary led the way in saying
we must have no impunity for war crimes
in ukraine is that a yes do you feel
that some people will be held
accountable with war i certainly hope so
i think for any crimes there should be
accountability
and i think that message needs to go out
now and what we hope is it will have a
deterrent impact on those commanders
that are at risk of facing uh illegal
orders to uh engage in attacks which
will harm civilians meantime back home
um you're also bringing in new
legislation today tell us about that
well we're announcing uh the outcome of
our root and branch review of parole uh
there have been a number of celebrated
cases which have created huge concern
anxiety for victims and the public we
think of the war boys case colin
pitchfork uh and we said we would
we said that we would do a root branch
review i'm announcing the details of
what were our proposals today they will
look at everything from the role of
victims i think their voice should be
heard more clearly during the parole
process but above all particularly for
dangerous offenders i want to make sure
the
process is re-anchored back into the
primary and overriding focus on
protecting the public particularly for
the top tier of more dangerous offenders
where the risk and assessing risk of
what they might do in the future is so
difficult to predict with any precision
okay you mentioned the visa applications
the homes for ukrainians only a thousand
people have been allowed in so far i
believe that's what the minister was
telling us yesterday i think it's a
thousand applications i understand per
day and we're going to this week set out
the the data so people can see how many
non at the moment no i don't know the
answer because we're about to publish
the data i think there's 200 000
sponsors that have come forward my
understanding is that around a thousand
applications are processed per day
you're right asking well yeah about how
many have actually been offered that
data is now going to be put forward very
shortly understand okay talk to me about
partygate here it comes um we've heard
from the police they made a statement
how significant
is it that they've started to issue
fines
well i think uh we said that we needed
to have the independent sugray review we
respected that the met would be free to
of course um follow its investigation uh
they've come forward and up and and made
clear that there are uh 20 fixed penalty
notices so far so good so far and uh the
the prime minister is already being
clear
taken responsibility for the things that
shouldn't have happened in number 10
he's apologized for it and more than
that he's overhauled number 10. that's
already happened of course we wait to
see the outcome of the conclusion of the
met process and there will be an
opportunity then for an update on sue
gray's report and full transparency
around that yeah but i don't want again
no we don't want to yeah we know we know
in all the lies that hyperbole and and
uh talking about hypothetical questions
all that sort of question my question to
you was what is the significance of the
police statement from yesterday well the
20 individuals of the law have been
given yes inevitably uh the fixed
penalty notice is those that have uh
breached the regulations and we uh stand
by and support the fact that there
should be uh the the met process the the
su grey process uh and accountability
for this yeah because the prime minister
of course said previously all guidance
was followed completely
in number 10. how can that be true and
yet people also having broken the law
well i don't know
i don't know the the
full facts
of the fixed penalty notices and the
details of those individual cases but
the prime minister was uh telling the
house of commons and and the public uh
what he knew to the best of his ability
we obviously had all the questions the
claims that were made that's precisely
why the sugray
inquiry was set up and that's why uh
where there have been credible
allegations they've gone to the police
this is precisely because of those
questions and those challenges that
those processes have run their course
and we of course support that yeah but
on at least 20 occasions the law was
broken at number 10 downing street
where does the buck stop with that well
the pm's already said i mean i mean
ultimately individuals take
responsibility but the pm has already
said he takes responsibility he
apologized for the fact that things
happen in number 10 that shouldn't have
done um and uh more than that he's
overhauled the number 10 operation
people have been asking me already today
yes but what happens to those that have
had a fixed felony notice many people
have already left number 10 downing
street
and and i think you can see from his
actions and the fact that these
inquiries have taken place that we uh
believe engage and indeed embrace the
transparency and accountability that
that is that the public rights yeah but
the fact remains deputy prime minister
it's an actual fact that 20 people broke
the law in downing street when we were
in the middle of a pandemic when people
couldn't bury their loved ones when they
couldn't see their loved ones in nursing
homes care homes and they died 20 people
broke the law
who should be responsible for that where
does the book stop with that well
ultimately individuals we're all
responsible for what we do and that's
why uh the fixed penalty notices the the
appropriate punishment that the met have
handed out the pm has been clear that he
uh uh recognizes that um
the the things went wrong he's
apologized for that um and and we've got
the ongoing process to determine any
other individuals both um through the
met police investigation anyone else
that has broken the law um
and indeed there will be an opportunity
for sue gray uh and that inquiry to
update their findings and the pm's be
very clear they'll be full transparency
around that yeah but what does it say
about the culture when at least 20
people at least 20 fines have been
issued so far more to come we're told by
them what does it say about the culture
at number 10 at the time well look these
things are deeply regrettable what i
would also say is what does it say about
the culture at the time well i
understand what you're saying but my
experience and i was in at number 10
we've had this conversation before
was that look i'm not going to
excuse anything that happened that
shouldn't have done we've been very
clear about that though the punishments
have have already been uh meted out but
mike's some of them some of them of
course accept that
my experience and just telling you
honestly first hand was the incredible
pressure and hard work and dedication of
the overwhelming majority of people
working in number 10. i'm always quite
careful um
whilst engaging and embracing the
accountability that's right take place
to say that it's not right to tar all
the civil servants who've worked so hard
during this panel not doing that just
saying well no i think it's fair because
i because i don't accept um that that
the sort of caricature is right i saw a
lot of people working incredibly long
hours under incredible pressure doing
their very best on on 12 at least 12
occasions they broke the law set 12
separate events we're not talking about
the prime minister particularly because
we don't know whether he's going to find
or not as yet although we'll promise
that he will and i'm not going to ask
you whether he should step down because
i know what you're saying what i'm
saying is should we be anxious about the
culture of number 10 at the time well
look i think there clearly were things
that got wrong that's why the pm uh
overhauled the operation number 10
downing street um
it's well known the the the individuals
that have come in and the individuals
at least some of them that have left um
and that's because he takes it so
seriously we do take it so seriously
what i'm just saying is that my
experience say this across government uh
and government gets things wrong and
civil servants and lord those
politicians get things wrong as well if
you're asking me when i saw during the
pandemic huge number of people working
uh incredibly long hours on incredible
pressure to do the right thing okay just
before i let you go from friday if you
had a cough or a cold or other symptoms
that were flu-like would you test for
covert uh it would me personally i'd
take a judgment call on where i was
going and i think that's the common
sense uh and the process of getting back
to living with covid um and
uh us taking responsibility and do you
think that everybody should be able to
do that with a free lateral flow test
that we can't continue to provide the
natural flow tests uh uh free uh
in the way that we did before i think
there are a lot of emergency measures
which were quite quite right during the
mists of and the crucible of the
pandemic which we'll have to phase out
i'm afraid that that that follows and
that's because we've got all the other
things that we're funding as we build
back after the pandemic we've got the
covid backlog which the uh chancellor
has funded and the the health
secretaries uh is um
is tackling we i mean i know that we've
got the court recovery with all those
other things so it is part of the
transition out of the emergency pandemic
uh back to normal and i know we're out
of time but there is one other thing i
must just ask you about briefly and it's
the report that's coming out at 10
o'clock today as far as babies so many
babies having died i can't as a parent
you're a parent you can't even begin to
imagine the suffering that those parents
must have gone through how do you
reassure
pregnant women and their partners right
now today that they are safer safe to go
into hospitals to have their babies well
we do want to provide that reassurance i
can only imagine the heartbreak and then
the anxiety that spreads across
expectant mothers
and i think what you'll see is through
i'm sure it's the health secretary that
will be setting this out um a
the practical measures uh combined with
the recognition of what's gone wrong to
provide that uh reassurance
and confidence i think not just amongst
mothers but amongst the public at large
it is a really heartbreaking uh uh
series of uh issues that we've had to
grapple with i know you've got busy day
ahead i must let you go thank you very
much mr prime minister thank you quick
look at what's happening with the papers
reflecting on what the deputy pm's just
been saying to us russia's uh give up on
conquest of kiev is on the front page of
the telegraph as moscow redeploys troops
away from the capital citing efforts to
build trust in peace talks but the metro
describes it as russian roulette as the
u.s urges people to be clear-eyed about
what is happening on the ground
the times also looks at the us and
britain's doubts over the kremlin's
intentions
that's the latest as well from the
financial times
egypt's football association says its
players were racially abused and their
team bus was attacked as they lost out
on a place at the world cup final to
senegal fans show sean laters in the
eyes of liverpool star mohamed salah in
the penalty shootout after a nil-nil
draw with him
missing
helping senegal go through zelo's
anfield teammate sadio main scored the
winning kick to send the west african
nation to its third world cup
ali is here to tell us more uh about it
um hi ali so they were shining these
laser lights into his eyes and he
couldn't see
yeah i mean is that fair
i mean you could see those pictures the
green dots all over him we think it was
from the senegal fans as you say clearly
this is something that needs to be
looked into to give you a sense of the
stakes i mean this is a world cup
qualifier between senegal and egypt a
famous rivalry their match ended one all
they're going into the penalties um mo
salah goes up their star player to take
this first penalty and yet as i say we
saw there there's those green lights on
him and they lost 3-1 in penalties as
you said sergio monet
who's his liverpool teammate winning
that winning penalty but lasers have
been a problem before in football you
might remember last year the euro
semi-final against denmark and the fa
were charged 25 000 pounds because of
lasers being shown at kasper schmeichel
the danish um uh the danish uh
goalkeeper's face at the time so
um this has been an ongoing issue i
think you know it's obviously a good
night for senegal we can't forget that
and we don't know what would have
happened if it hadn't been for the
lasers but clearly i think questions are
going to be ongoing about how we make
sure this doesn't happen again and as
you mentioned you know questions around
whether there was a racial element to
this which is obviously very serious and
is going to be an important part too
okay for now ali thanks so much indeed
ali developing that story for us
throughout the course of the morning
here on sky news um i just want to bring
you some breaking news as far as the
baftas are concerned um
channel four uh the series it's a sin is
leading the nominations uh for the
television awards
running for 11 separate gongs caroline
frost standing by for us was with us
earlier in the week to talk about the
oscars um caroline i know that you've
been monitoring this um with us it's
weird time for them to make these
announcements but there we go talk us
through it
okay well as you say the big headline is
uh russell t davis's channel four drama
it's a sin being just recognized almost
across the board i think we can safely
guarantee okay that it will be going
home with not just a couple of awards on
um in may because it it's just caught
the imagination it's it's it's his story
it's a huge passion project for russell
t davis he said it's the drama that he's
been wanting to write all his adult life
it's about the 80s aids epidemic and how
young gay people specifically were
treated how first there was an era of
denial then confusion and a lot of
alienation and how and the young people
were made to feel during that time so um
i mean it's a story that i don't think i
mean it's been touched on in
documentaries nobody has given it the
attention and the thoroughness of
russell t davis's drama and so um quite
rightly it's come round finally it spent
years being incubated by him he took it
to different broadcasters channel four
gave him the love that it deserved and
he has been recognizing all these
leading nominations quite extraordinary
so wonderful look for him he was
recognized last night in similar
categories it led the board in the royal
television society awards as well so
clearly it has caught a good wind
i'm just uh hearing that landscape as
olivia coleman one of our own um
productions of course here on skydot
doing very well as well i think seven
nominations oh my goodness well i mean
anything that olivia coleman touches
turns to gold doesn't it i mean she is
our our blossoming national treasure if
she's not already she's an oscar winner
she's a golden globe winner she's an
emmy winner and it may be that she is
yet another bafta winner for that
wonderful portrayal and together with
david thulis i mean it was it's a
beautiful drama about we do seem to have
a fascination at the moment with people
who skirt around the edges of society
and don't always follow a mainstream
route and this was a story of a couple
who uh decided that they would they were
the best people to be responsible for
their family's inheritance and that they
would spend it their very own way not
always in accordance with the law i
should add but um the story is a
thrilling one and it was beautifully
told and it is still available on the
now platform so yes another gong
possibly for olivia coleman
uh yeah i remember in w1a all that time
ago when she used to say not a problem
not a problem whatever the question was
and look where she is um now when are
the one of the actual awards
right so they are in may on the sunday
the eighth of may a host yet to be
announced we had richard awadi last year
but i think everyone is looking forward
to these awards this year because tv has
proved itself over the last two years
not to be the poor relation of film
anymore but very much on equal peggings
and we also know okay that awards
ceremonies are not as
predictable and tedious as they may have
been thought of before
okay thanks very much indeed caroline
we'll chat to you again later for now
thank you
lots to talk to the chair of the health
select committee about now and of course
former health secretary jeremy hunt mr
hunt thank you for joining us on the
program this morning we're going to hear
later on today what happened in
shrewsbury but you know the headline is
lots of babies died and they didn't need
to
yes i think it's going to be a very
sobering morning i commissioned this
report back in 2016 when
uh two families came to see me and they
were worried about the circumstances
surrounding the death of
their children and um i'm afraid it
mushroomed having started investigating
the complaints from 23 families
uh don ockendon ended up looking at
nearly 2 000 cases but one thing i would
say kay it's very important i was
listening to your interview just now
with dominic raab
the nhs facilitates the birth of nearly
600 000 babies every year the vast
majority are totally safe
and indeed they're getting safer um but
i think today's report is going to be a
very sobering read
yeah we saw what happened in
mid-staffordshire and that was of course
under a previous government's watch um
you were in charge weren't you when we
saw what happened in shropshire
learning from experience what can we
learn about what why we didn't learn the
lessons of what happened i know slightly
different circumstances but the bottom
line is that life is a life is a life
absolutely i mean
baby deaths have come down by about a
third over the last decade
but we're still
27th out of 38 oecd countries when it
comes to infant mortality so
countries like hungaria and slovenia do
better than us
and i think from i haven't seen the
report but i think what we'll see is
that staffing is very important my
select committee said we needed 2 000
more midwives and 500 more doctors
today unfortunately the government is
going to vote down an amendment to the
health bill which would mean that we
always trained enough doctors and nurses
for the future which is very very
disappointing but staffing is one
another is this so-called natural births
ideology
which put pressure on mothers to avoid
c-sections
even when that might have been the safer
option and i think that is something
which
uh thankfully the nhs has now removed
all targets associated with reducing
c-sections
but trust me healthy was one of the
trusts which had the lowest one of the
lowest c-section rates in the nhs
and the third thing is the blame culture
um i mean even in this inquiry
uh donna ockendon believes that doctors
nurses midwives were pressurized not to
be open with her
and told there could be professional
reprisals
if they were and
too often in the nhs it's difficult for
doctors and nurses to speak out it's the
thing they really want to do to learn
from the stakes but we make it too hard
it's a fourth point funding as well uh
given the first part of the ochenton uh
report which was published last year as
you know an extra at 95 million pounds i
believe was made available by nhs
england uh in funding for maternity care
there wasn't enough money available
there's always pressures on funding in
all health systems because of the aging
population now of course the pandemic
pressures but i think if you ask people
in the nhs today they would say that
staffing shortfalls is a bigger issue
sometimes they have the money to pay for
doctors nurses midwives but they can't
find the people to actually do the roles
and that is because over very many years
we haven't been training enough doctors
and nurses i set up five new medical
schools but even that may not have been
enough
and that's why i think we need to have a
long-term overhaul of our workforce
planning because it takes so long to
train people up and you you can't just
do it overnight
and overseas stuff being prevented from
coming into the country
by a conservative government
well there is an nhs visa um so it
shouldn't be the case that anyone is
prevented from coming in but i think
uh the truth is that immigration and
getting doctors from overseas was always
a get out of jail card for the nhs over
very many years
but now with the pandemic we have a two
million shortage of doctors around the
world a 15 million shortage of nurses
and we've got to be honest and say we're
we're a proper health system we should
be training the number of doctors and
nurses we need and frankly is it ethical
for us to be recruiting so many doctors
from much poorer countries where they
are often desperately needed at home
would you test yourself on friday um
after the lateral flows are no longer
available if you had a cough or a cold
well i would um
i understand why um the government says
we have to get back to normal
all i would say is that we just need to
keep a weather eye on all of this
because
you know we have got a big spike in
infections at the moment it doesn't look
like it's translating into people being
seriously ill we have got to get back to
normal at some stage
but we need to be prepared to change
course very quickly if the situation
changes if we had a new variant for
example i think the lesson of the
pandemic
is that you have to be willing to change
course quickly if the facts on the
ground change
so are you telling people at home that
they should test themselves if they have
the symptoms of a cough or of a cold or
flu
yes we should and you know that's the
same as you know taking your temperature
if you think you might have flu i mean
we have
got a lot of covered around it can be
very dangerous indeed particularly to
people who aren't vaccinated but we are
going to have to move you know given the
billions of pounds that the testing
program is costing i mean i'm someone
who's criticized aspects of the
government's response to the pandemic
but i do recognize we have got to move
to
some type of normality so um it's a
difficult judgment as to when that
happens and i would just say if the
situation changes we might need to look
again at that decision
what about those people that can't
afford to buy the tests
well i hope we will find ways to make
sure that they are able to access the
tests they need
okay talk to me about partygate before i
let you go basically um the first
tranche of fines are in 20
separate fines we don't know if it's 20
separate people what we do know is that
there was a culture a dining street
where people were breaking the law when
we were in the midst of that lockdown
that you were just talking about what's
your interpretation of what should
happen next
well i think it's very serious the whole
thing um but i think we don't yet know
the full facts um there is an
investigation going on you know we don't
know whether the prime minister himself
is going to be asked to pay a fine we
don't know the full supreme report and
i'm not saying that to sort of
dodge your questions on it k but i just
think that it is this is a legal
situation and so for people like me to
make a judgment on for example the prime
minister's role i think we do have to
know
whether the police think that he has
broken the law or not and we don't yet
know that no i'm not i think
no i know you're not but i'm just but
you know these are very serious issues
and i like all mps i've got a lot of
constituents who are very very angry
about them
yeah my question i suppose is about the
culture um
at the very heart very top of government
where at
just the first tranche we've seen that
the law was broken on 20 separate
occasions at the very heart of
government
and that is wrong and i don't think we
can defend that i think we can
understand the pressures that people
were under in downing street in the
middle of that national emergency
working all the hours that god gives but
we can't defend breaking the rules that
they set for everyone else no we can't
okay good to talk to you can i hear one
of your little ones in the background
there you can indeed i'm about to cycle
her to school
okay good i better let you do that then
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thank you
thank you
tamara's here morning tomorrow morning
kay well what's going on with partygate
look boris johnson's going to face more
tough questions about it at lunchtime at
prime minister's questions and later
this afternoon in front of the liaison
committee of mps we don't know who got
those 20 fines yesterday the met police
will not be saying who got one and it
may take a few days for them to land on
people's doorsteps i thought dominick
robb said something very interesting
which was when you asked about the
significance of people at the top of
government whoever they may be having
broken the rules broken the law he said
the prime minister had apologized and he
has overhauled downing street so
suggesting that some people did lose
their jobs because of this
poor culture failures of leadership at
the top now this is why it becomes a
problem for boris johnson if he does get
a fine because people have resigned over
breaking the rules notably the former
health secretary matt hancock so if he
does get a fine and tries to ride it out
then he is going to fake he's already
facing calls from opposition parties but
that's where it becomes tricky for tory
mps yes a lot of them were saying he
should resign earlier this year and
those calls have calmed down a bit they
all look very jolly when they were
heading out for their dinner at a hotel
last night but the mood could quickly
turn if the prime minister does get one
of those fines and it becomes difficult
to reconcile him staying with what
others are doing the other thing that
our viewers this morning morning
wherever you're watching us
on the breakfast show on the sky is
lateral flows yes so from friday the 1st
of april you will no longer be able to
get free natural flow tests from a
pharmacy because they are costing a lot
of money and the government says we need
to start pairing back there will be some
exceptions announced last night care
homes nhs staff people who are
clinically vulnerable will still be able
to get those tests but that won't cover
everyone who feels that they want one
and it will mean that people
who don't who have fixed incomes and
aren't able to afford two pounds per
lateral flow test will may have symptoms
but not take one and um the health
secretary has said look we have to draw
the line somewhere but you heard jeremy
hunt there sounding a real note of
caution saying the government needs to
keep a close eye on this case numbers
according to the ons survey have never
been higher okay for now tomorrow thank
you tomorrow's take nine o'clock looking
forward to it thank you and of course
we'll have full live coverage of pmq's
that's of course at 12 o'clock
today we know that is very popular with
you guys and that is uh live
unedited
12 o'clock today here on sky news
let's tell you what's happening in
ukraine the people of chinese have been
told they could be getting some relief
from a bombardment that has left the
city in ruins and thousands barely
managing to survive it's been surrounded
by russian troops all routes are blocked
and basic supplies have been almost
completely exhausted our correspondent
sally lockwood spoke to residents about
their struggle to survive and now
reports from lev
any ceasefire will come too late for
many here most of cherna have already
destroyed an unknown number of its
residents already dead
in the rubble here bodies are being
covered with blankets it's too
distressing to broadcast
someone carried away in a makeshift
stretcher
the city on russia's ruthless path from
belarus to kiev is now surrounded and
cut off
sky news has been sent these pictures to
show what that means for people trapped
here
this is jana and her ten-year-old
daughter polina
like most here a bomb shelter is now
their home
how do you comfort a child when this is
it
we have a big family here there are 17
people we can't go away and leave an 85
year old grandmother a mom or a brother
with a two-year-old
the little food left is being shared
around by local volunteers like xenia
the road barely visible through her
shattered windscreen
we managed to speak to her briefly after
she charged her phone on a generator
which is rationed to one hour a day
connection here is it's very bad when
we're hearing the
bump sound
the person what we can do we can call
our relatives that live nearby to ask if
it's okay was it near to your home and
with the absence of the electricity we
don't have the siren
we've lost xenia again
just as she was describing how desperate
things have become in chennai have it's
also quite clear that not only are they
without power
but they're without internet phone
signal as well and just almost any
ability to communicate with the outside
world
it's little wonder chernohiv is being
called the next mario pole the opposite
end of the country but an almost
identical humanitarian catastrophe
an azov unit that first began as a
far-right voluntary group still holds
the center of the city
one of its fighters eli speaks to me
from an undisclosed location in mariopol
putin's pretext
for invading ukraine for starting this
war was to denazify
the country was he talking about you me
and my comrades were accused of like
neo-nazis like uh also nationally
far-right swings wing
white supremacist
uh and all the words like this putin
declaring that he is going to generify
the ukraine yeah
or demilitarize and deny
clay
and right now they they're bombing the
kindergarten school medical medical
facility
before eli signs off he says he's
confident they can hold mario paul but
without some hope of a break in fighting
it's unclear how long civilians can hold
on for sally lockwood sky news
in western ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
you